la moldavie n'est pas en guerre
mais avare ni de ça elle est dans tous
les esprits
car au bout du village c'est la
transnistrie une bande de terre
séparatistes gardé par des soldats
russes la moldavie estime qu'il serait
1500 sur ce territoire reconnu par aucun
état
alors pour récupérer l'argent envoyés
depuis l'étranger où disposer d'une
carte bancaire internationale ses
habitants doivent se rendre à vingt dix
ans
à la mairie les transnistrien sont
également nombreux à franchir la
frontière pour renouveler leur passeport
moldave occasion
renseigner comme quoi
la 6e
étape
fuir combattre il y a trente ans ces
vétérans moldaves ont stoppé l'avancée
des séparatistes pro russes
face à la menace russe la moldavie vient
de demander son adhésion à l'union
européenne
la transnistrie réclame elle sa
reconnaissance en tant qu'etat auprès
des nations unies